[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
doing a great job of just
rim running right here and he's such a
big body
and everyone's just used to him shooting
at five here's middleton
a checklist by middleton but lopez gabby
[Applause]
lopez
first five minutes of this ball game and
they get the switch again if they want
but they can't beat lopez off the
dribble
this is the way lopez played in game two
which was a victory for the bucks after
they lost game one who's mcdonald's
kicking it to the corner
just didn't beat the shot clock and
capela keeps a live streak
by lopez
[Applause]
[Music]
the fox 20 the hulk's seventh
what a start for milwaukee at both ends
of the floor they are locked in
defensively here
i'm out call by nate mcmillan this is
the type of defense
and intensity we saw in game two and
that's your center
coming up with a steal and crazy eyes
with the crazy dunk
bobby port is in the bucks rolling
well a rookie out of usc
what a beautiful dunk right here both
bobby portis originally a first round
pick of the chicago bulls and spent
three and a half seasons
with chicago here's lopez
[Applause]
out there and guard the ball no weak
side help
no uh defense on the ball uh they're
just out scrapping it
back in game two they get 22
pointers that's been the three-point
right foot on the line for a long two
here gets the
friendly sitting out with the
hyper-extended me
potterton on the steal this tucker
met by reddish leaves it to portis
portis takes it home
[Music]
[Applause]
14 points here's the contact by golinari
[Music]
and the concentration knocking it down
bob myers is there for the build-up of
the warriors director of player
personnel
[Applause]
lopez
[Applause]
there's portis with his size able to jet
back
in this game get into the paint and
they've dominated the paint area 48
points in the
another three-point attempt for mark so
he's four for seven
from three-point land middleton
the low pack
[Applause]
he actually decoyed williams into
thinking he had a clear pass
bobby portis it's been a 12-4
milwaukee run prior to that shot
by lou williams the lead for lopez
[Applause]
for me to get to the nba finals and it
is all floods out of here
lopez with that deep hook so they've
done it
at both ends middleton
the tortoise
i'm just saying nothing is guaranteed
and will you ever be back in this spot
where you're two wins away
from the indian final the hookshot
artist
rick lopez career night for brooke lopez
in the playoffs and 45 left to the point
how today into the lane for locals
[Applause]
hook here and then another assist
drew did their normal job of making
plays for everyone and when everyone
score and everyone's doing their thing
that's tough for the defense it's up for
them to make a decision and commitment
thank you nice job